les prix des produits d'alimentation au
pays augmentent à un rythme jamais vu
depuis 40 ans c'est ce que souligne le
Bureau de la concurrence qui lance une
vaste étude pour comprendre la dynamique
concurrentielle entre les entreprises
même s'il ne s'agit pas d'une enquête
cette révision des pratiques est
accueillie avec soulagement par les
consommateurs qui espèrent ainsi mieux
comprendre ou va leur argent
le double du profit dans les dernières
années c'est trop pourquoi on se demande
tous pourquoi alors
une friterie depuis 12 ans à Montréal
quand elle compare les prix des aliments
avec celui des grandes chaines des
questions demeure sans réponse j'arrive
pas à comprendre j'ai des produits
moi-même ici que je vais en bain moins
cher que les autres puis pourtant on a
toutes les mêmes produits au Canada 80%
du marché de l'alimentation est détenu
par 5 grands joueurs il est plus que
temps que le Bureau de la concurrence se
penche sur leur pratique commerciale qui
peuvent être déloyales croient cette
contraire notamment pour les commerces
indépendants alors c'est important pour
le bureau de mieux comprendre les enjeux
et peut-être
d'adopter un changement de ton un
changement de style à long terme
l'enquête sur le pain dure depuis 7 ans
et on a pas eu un rapport encore
l'inflation dans le domaine de
l'alimentation a bondit de 11,4% au
cours de la dernière année par rapport à
6,9% pour le reste des produits de
consommation oui c'est le temps qui se
penchent là-dessus parce qu'il y a de
quoi qui se passe à quelque part il y a
quelque chose mais full régler parce que
les gens ont pu les moyens l'association
des détaillants en alimentation du
Québec compte se défendre auprès du
Bureau de la concurrence on va leur
demander surtout c'est de regarder pas
juste uniquement le détail alimentaire
mais l'ensemble la chaîne
agroalimentaire parce que l'augmentation
des prix
touche l'ensemble de la chaîne
alimentaire que ce soit la production
que ta transformation la distribution
également le détail le consommateur lui
voit que le prix à la fin n'a le panier
d'épicerie le Bureau de la concurrence
émettra ensuite ces recommandations au
gouvernement les parties intéressées
sont invités à présenter leurs
observations au Bureau de la concurrence
sur ces questions jusqu'au 16 décembre
le bureau présentera son rapport final
en juin 2023 ici Elise Allard
Radio-Canada Montréal